hello readers let's talk about
illustrations when you're reading a
story and it has pictures in it don't
skip them you could be missing out on a
wealth of information and added detail
good readers use pictures to help them
understand stories even better let's
talk about why that is
pictures can help describe the mood of a
story or how a story makes you feel if
I'm telling a story about a girl and her
dad going for a walk in the woods but
then when you see an image of those
woods and the trees are all spindly and
black and the sky is a leaden grey what
does that tell you about the mood of the
story it's grim it's creepy it's a scary
walk in some scary woods the way the
story feels can be expressed through the
illustrations pictures can help describe
the events of a story maybe the story is
a little unspecific say for instance
we're talking about Little Red Riding
Hood and it says the big bad wolf
swallows Rani up and disguises himself
as her but it doesn't go into further
detail Oh what does that mean what does
his disguise look like and we can look
at an illustration like this and say
okay that big bulge in the wolf's
stomach is where granny is and the
wolf's got on granny's bonnet and little
glasses and also that's his disguise it
is not very convincing to me but what do
I know and pictures can help fill in
important details I can look at a
character's expression as I'm reading to
help me answer questions I might have
about how that character feels what's
going on there with the face of the wolf
is that a smile is that a grimace the
text can give me a clue but then the
picture can tell me the rest of the
story we can use our knowledge of how
real-life people are or behave to help
understand pictures in a story the wolf
for example the face he's making with
his eyes narrowed and his brows knit
like that and that smile creeping across
his features to me that's a scheming
face that's the face someone makes when
they're talking to themselves and
planning something nasty he's also
putting on granny's bonnet and glasses
we know these aren't things wolves are
known to wear and he seems very pleased
with himself so he's eaten granny he's
putting on her clothes he seems really
happy about it but in an evil way and we
can use that
to inform the way we read the story this
wolf isn't satisfied with eating an old
woman he wants to eat her grandkid for
dessert so greedy what a greedy mean
little beast
the point is that pictures and stories
are really useful read them the same way
you read words understanding images will
make you a stronger reader and if you
can learn that why then you can learn
anything David out